hey what's up y'all what is good so much
for doing the show
um i really really appreciate it i know
it's an awkward thing we tried to make
it look like my show
like and i love that is that not a real
background is that like a virtual
background
no dude they ca this is my formal living
room and they it's gone and they
literally put a whole set up behind me
donald are you in a closet i am in my
closet this is where i escape
reality i escaped the wife i escaped the
kids
and this is also where we do the podcast
it is funny in this like pandemic time
to find especially we were in like a
cabin in montana and now i'm in l.a but
we're in a cabin montana it's so small
and there's like nowhere to go and like
literally would end up in a bathroom
yeah this is weird this is weird we
started we
started uh recording the podcast and
donald needed to find a place that was
like good for sound
and so he started his closet and then he
realized that his
kids didn't want to come in there and
his wife would leave him alone and so
now i think his whole family thinks he
makes the podcast like every day
he's just i'm in here absolutely
absolutely absolutely sometimes i doodle
[Laughter]
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel please don't
make me keep going